welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus Docker this is a
special episode of the podcast featuring
Nathan lebens interviewing Jan Talon Yan
is the founder of Skype and a co-founder
of the future of Life Institute
Nathan is the founder of waymark which
is an AI video creation company and he
is also the co-host of the cognitive
Revolution podcast
I really enjoy listening to that podcast
because of Nathan's careful approach to
discussing both the enormous upside and
the potential risks of AI
if you're new to that podcast I
recommend starting with episode 15 on
gpt4 and economic transformation and
episode 31 on the modes of top AI
companies and without further Ado here
is Nathan lebens interviewing Jan talin
Our Guest today is Jan talin Yan is a
technologist entrepreneur and investor
whose unique life Journey has
intersected with some of the most
important social and technological
events of our Collective lifetime
born in 1972 in then Soviet Estonia Yan
was 17 years old when the Berlin Wall
fell and he quickly became a video game
entrepreneur
years later he created Kasa the famous
P2P file sharing platform that at its
peak accounted for half of all internet
traffic
from there he went on to co-found Skype
which eventually sold to eBay in 2005
for 2.5 billion dollars and for years
remained the most successful internet
company founded outside of the United
States
Circa 2009 Yan came across Eliezer
utkowski's AI risk writing which he
found extremely persuasive and which
inspired him to dedicate his time
resources and personal credibility to
existential risk mitigation with a
particular focus on AI
yard has since invested in nearly 180
startups including dozens of AI
application layer companies and some
half dozen startup Labs that focus on
fundamental AI research those include
Deep Mind anthropic and most recently
conjecture
he's done all this in an effort to
support the teams that he believes most
likely to lead us to AI safety and to
have a seat at the table at
organizations that he worries might take
on too much risk
he's also founded several philanthropic
non-profits including the future of Life
Institute which recently published The
Open Letter calling for a six-month
pause on the development of AI systems
more powerful than gpt4
with so much happening in AI right now I
decided to touch on Yan's personal story
and to discuss eliezer's Baseline AI
safety worldview only briefly in the
first part of today's conversation
instead we focused on the current state
of AI development and safety including
Yan's expectations for possible economic
transformation
what catastrophic failure modes worry
him most in the near term
How likely he believes Next Generation
systems like gpt5 are to literally end
the world
how big of a bullet we dodged with the
training of gpt4
whether in some sense we are lucky that
language models are softer and slower
than alternative AI paradigms
which organizations really matter for
immediate term pause purposes
to what extent those organizations are
currently coordinating or slowing down
already
how AI race Dynamics are likely to
evolve over the next couple of years
what Yan and his team hoped to
accomplish by calling for a six-month
pause and finally how it's gone and how
he's feeling about it all now
if nothing else I hope this conversation
makes it clear that the pausers are not
merely luddites who have never built and
don't understand technology
on the contrary Yan's personal
achievements world-class Investment
Portfolio and evident optimism for an AI
enabled future should we manage to build
one safely
show that at least some of our most
sophisticated and accomplished thinkers
take existential risks from AI extremely
seriously
with that I hope you enjoy this
conversation with janton
Jan talin welcome to the cognitive
Revolution thanks for having me really
excited to have you you have been a I
think quiet but major player in the
development of AI over the last 10 or so
years now and I want to give people just
a very quick kind of overview of who you
are and the role you've played
um and then kind of jump to the Future
which is the present
um and talk about all the things that
have happened in the last few months as
well as the call that you recently
participated in putting out as part of
the future of Life Institute to call for
this six-month pause in the development
of large-scale models
um so a lot to cover the uh the world is
moving faster than ever it seems but
maybe just give us a little bit of an
intro to yourself as an investor in AI
companies you can tell a little bit if
you want about the the story of how you
came to be in position to invest in AI
companies but really super interested in
how you have have managed to become an
investor in so many leading companies
and the philosophy that that supports
that so skip over the period of becoming
an entrepreneur uh running my own games
company
uh than getting into development of
peer-to-peer technology that culminated
with Skype and then at the end of my
Skype career stumbled upon Alia
zaratkowski's writings and going like
holy hell what what the thing is what is
the world that I've been born into uh
and uh having a meeting with Eliezer
like almost exactly 14 years ago
where I'm gonna try to poke at his
arguments didn't find any holes and then
I thought okay
how can I help uh send them some money
but I think more important they started
taking those arguments turning around
and uh
you know presenting it those arguments
to people who would want to have some
brand behind the person who is like
making documents um and that's how
basically the Cambridge Center for the
study vaccines risk got started where I
convinced my co-founder here price there
that these topics are important and Max
take Mark I think KR already was kind of
like very
primed to these arguments but that's how
the future of Life got started
future flight Institute
uh and the other side that I deployed
was okay yeah I am I already was like a
bit of an investor and I thought that
perhaps I could kind of use my brand uh
to
uh sort of get a foot uh in the door uh
in like various companies or developing
potential dangerous things so I did
invest in a bunch of
AI companies just to I mean always had
this dilemma of of not wanting took
enough
direct the accelerate them so I I try to
not be like majority investor or
anything but I just enough to have a
voice and then basically it kind of
with deepmind I actually had to like
walk up the demise at the conference uh
and that's that's how we're going to
start talking and eventually I became
friends I still catch up with him like
uh every second time I'm in London or so
but like and then I was here once you're
or once I already was investor in
deepmind and eventually a board member
like getting the air of other AI
companies became easier so it's kind of
like has been like uh just worked my way
up so to speak
yeah I think a lot of VCS would be
extremely envious of your deal flow so I
want to get back to that a little bit
more in a second but let's just go to
the Eleazar moment for a second so you
said this was 14 years ago so this takes
us back to Circa 2009
at the time the Deep learning Revolution
hasn't even really started yet
it's a you know at that point a kind of
Highly
um well this may not you may object to
this but I would say for me I read it as
a highly speculative yet very compelling
thought about what might happen and you
know the arguments were there was a lot
of detail to be filled in where it was
like well we have this you know insane
amount of compute and like we're
probably going to figure out how to use
it and then that probably goes very bad
for us so how did you understand like
what do you think is kind of the
strongest version of that original
argument and then what have been the
biggest changes to that world view in
the intervening time yeah I mean they're
like many ways to uh frame things frame
the problem uh sometimes I've been kind
of asking people to questions like hey
can you program and B do you have
children uh until I get like four
different uh kind of framings or
approaches I can explain
the situation with AI like one sort of
simple argument is that uh look there is
a reason why chimpanzees are not
determining the future and haven't been
determining the future for like a long
time uh if ever
and humans like humans are but perhaps
not for long because we are
working furiously to get rid of that
advantage that we have over Uber as they
can collected Apex species on this
planet
uh so uh so once you're going to realize
that AI
will
likely not stop at human level uh there
is this uh
unfortunate narrative especially that's
very uh widespread in Asia where people
a lot of people think that like we are
going to make AI smarter and smarter up
to the point where it becomes conscious
and then it's just like us then it's
just like just like people other people
and we need to kind of integrate them
give them give it voting rights and
whatnot whereas I think this is just
completely
illusionary tale it will probably not be
conscious uh it will just be very
competent and competence and
consciousness
they might be related somehow but
probably not so we will have just
control over the future yanked from our
hands so that's I think is
for me compelling enough story
yeah so the linchpin there is
we're the boss of the world because
we're the smartest thing around and if
we change that there's a pretty good
chance that we may not be the boss of
the world anymore and not only that but
we really you know at this point as
things are starting to come online we
don't have a great understanding of what
the new boss would look like or what it
might want or even how to conceptualize
you know things like want in the context
of its internal uh workings so any would
you anything you would object to in my
kind of very brief uh extension and and
then you know how has your mindset
shifted also from the kind of you know
purely theoretical largely purely
theoretical 2009 Les or arguments versus
today where we're in this world of
large language models obviously but also
you know increasingly multimodal large
language models and you know agent style
systems like agato you know that can do
all sorts of things
um how is the actual development of the
technology changed how you think about
it yeah so many things to say about that
um first of all yeah like I think
I just agree uh the way your phrase
things like one sometimes I've been
saying that like look we are we are
seeing the tail end possibly last years
of something like a hundred thousand
year period during which humans were the
boss on this planet
uh and uh and like it could be even even
more extreme it's it's unclear If
evolution will continue if
self-replicators will continue uh once
once you have ai it's just completely uh
taking the solar system to like uh down
to atom levels and rebuilding it and the
rest of the universe uh so like like it
might even be like tail end of like a 4
billion year period uh so how am I think
has changed yeah it's I mean it has been
like this abstract argument that look uh
if we just continue on this trend we're
gonna accelerating towards a cliff and I
think the current situation is that we
seem to be starting to see that
shape of the cliff uh through the fog
it's possible that this is still a
mirage and like false alarm and uh like
things were gonna level out then we need
like some new paradigms so but uh but
the current situation is like it's it it
seems more likely than not that this is
it
uh and when it comes to
General Trend I think it has been like
very unfortunate in AI research with
some like Silver Linings the unfortunate
trend has been like we have gone from
kind of more transparent more
understandable paradigms uh to less and
less understandable paradigms we went
from like things like expert systems
they're like by definition they're very
super understandable people were just
interviewing experts and trying to kind
of hand code the rules uh by which
experts are are making decisions uh into
a machine and that was like 80s it was
really big big thing in 80s then we went
to uh supervised learning where people
was just labeling data in different
different domains uh trying to
distinguish numbers and this is like
where the Deep learning kind of started
to shine first and now we are in
unsupervised learning it's just like
true we don't even care much about what
what data we throw it's just like
through a lot of data uh at Ai and have
it ask it to just well figure it out in
what kind of universe you are what kind
of heuristics you should apply what kind
of skills you need to need to learn in
order to predict the next token uh and
that is like I call it
summon and tame Paradigm which is like
you just use these like multi hundred
million
large experiments to summon an
uncontrollable controllable mind and
then you look at like what it looks like
and try to tame it so and this like kind
of works if the mind is not very
powerful but it might not be
might not work for very long but let's
go back and just touch on the investment
side for a second because I think this
will help people understand the point of
view that you have right I mean it it
started with a series of blog posts in
2009 but now you're really quite the AI
Insider
um you did a recent interview where you
kind of ran through your Investment
Portfolio in more detail but I thought
it was interesting how you
split it into kind of two categories one
being like the fundamental AI research
type company that you've invested in I
believe there's a half a dozen of those
and then there's kind of the application
layer companies and it sounds like there
are
dozens you know maybe 50 plus of those
it seems like the big research companies
would be the ones that would kind of
give you more insight into
what's going on and what matters most
right now but maybe that's wrong so
um could you kind of just give a quick
run through of you know some of the
highlights of the portfolio and you know
get a little we can get a little sense
from that of kind of all the different
angles that you have on AI today yeah
I'm actually not the best person to talk
about my investments uh because like I
have mostly delegated the way to a team
of a few people
um I kind of still make the final
decisions
um but like my book was really is like
philanthropy but yeah when it comes to
Investments
yeah like the sort of fundamental
research
AR research companies I specifically
kind of like invested not to make money
but to have some kind of influence uh
over over what's happening inside those
companies so they are in some ways kind
of adjacent to my philanthropy
and like when it comes to applied AI I
think the prospects of Applied air
companies like much worse now than they
used to be before this like Lodge llm
Paradigm but of course like the telem
Paradigm is like very new so there was
like no way to know that
um like in
like I don't know five ten years ago
uh but currently I
I mean I think we have had this
discussion with you that that like the
the big problem with applying
trying to build and applied AI company
using telem Paradigm is that you have to
be ready for the rock being pulled out
from your like next six months to a year
work by the next generation of llm which
is like
a new crop of capabilities that have
been bred so it's uh
in a way
like this the more domain specific is
the AI competence the more value there
is in building kind of uh application
layers around this competence whereas I
give you just I get this like General
increasingly General generally competent
Minds it's much harder to build
applications in a stable way
yeah I one of the um interesting things
about doing this show and talking to all
the people that we have is not to spoil
one of our closing questions but we
often ask
what AI products people are using today
that they recommend to the audience and
I have been really Amazed by how few
different answers we've heard
probably two-thirds of people have said
like well basically just use you know
chat GPT that's it you know we get a
couple other mentions
um but it has led me to believe that the
application layer faces some very
serious challenges
um and it reminds me of you know kind of
other hyperscaling platforms that we've
seen over the last you know couple
decades where
you build around the edges of them but
the monopolist power is just so big I do
want to ask a little bit more about the
competing Trends between like
centralization and decentralization
because I don't think it's obvious at
all that it like plays out as it did for
Google and as it did for Facebook this
time around well let's just cover you
know kind of the the flagship maybe
that's the wrong word but you know the
fundamental research company Investments
deepmind uh was the first I know that
you're also an investor in anthropic
um and have supported ought I don't know
if that's an investment or if that's
like a just a donation conjecture is on
that list
who am I missing on the list and I'm
also really interested in terms of the
conversations that you've had with
Founders as somebody you know just given
your statement I'm sure you said the
same to them like I'm not really doing
this to make money I'm doing it because
I want to have your ear in case
something important comes up like how do
people react to that do they say like
yeah that's great I want you to be in
that position to have my ear or people
sort of like uh I don't know what to
make of you yeah maybe you're only
investing in a line to people yeah I
found it like really in general my my
kind of as an investor uh to uh to
deep tech companies is that look I'm
investing my own money I don't have a
boss right so and I have like a sizeable
philanthropic operation so if I can kind
of do good by walking away from profits
I can do that uh in a way that like VCS
are at least
for them it's harder to do that because
they manage other people's money and
like for them it's kind of like
yeah in some ways like LPS or or their
bosses so like a I will be on the side
of Founders if they think that like
there's like some hit I feel like uneasy
I'm not gonna push you to take like this
uh defense contractor or or whatnot and
that this this usually kind of goes down
pretty well uh uh with Founders because
yeah it's it's true
so who am I missing on the list we get
deepmind anthropic conjecture ought
who else would you put in that
fundamentals bucket I'm actually not an
investor and I have uh don't like I have
uh sent some philanthropic money money
that way though so yeah I mean vicarious
uh was like uh a long time investment
around the same time then Deep Mind and
like a few
few other kind of AGI groups that are
not less less not as well known like
curios.ai for example
uh there is this uh
improbable.ai if I forget if I remember
correctly in UK um yeah I I it's just
like I have like 180 Investments or
something like that and so I don't
quickly recall all of all the
all the names from them but they're
conjecture I think very highly of
conjecture in fact I kind of whenever I
go to London I try to hang out hang out
in their office because they are they
seem to be like a company that a group
that has like the highest respect for AI
in a sense that like this could be like
really dangerous and like the dangerous
stuff important part here to focus on
rather than like whatever exciting
commercial contracts we can squeeze out
of it or something so let's talk about
that
um kind of emerging Paradigm of danger I
mean this has obviously been all over
the discourse lately with the pause
letter and eliezer's timepiece and I
think broadly speaking
the public is extremely confused because
on the one hand we have Eliezer and then
on the Other Extreme we still have
people routinely saying like this is all
nothing you know this is all just hype
and it'll never amount to anything
um which seems crazy to me at this point
like almost like self-evidently this is
a big deal
but that is still out there and you know
for folks like my parents who like you
know don't rush to try GPT they're just
kind of hearing all these different
messages from you know the media and
it's it's all just very confusing so
let's start with maybe the neutral or
ideally even positive side people are
you know throwing around AGI like all
over the place a lot of disagreement or
you know probably mostly implicit
disagreement on what does that even mean
maybe we could just start with like what
do you think AI is going to do for us in
Daily Life we'll we'll then extend to
like the dangers that it can pose but
what is your kind of expectation for how
AI is going to impact Our Lives over the
next few years
I think it's really kind of dependent on
um like how
capable the planet is in uh kind of
constraining uh The Logical experiments
because if it turns out that we can't
constrain them and and slow them down
then we're just gonna die that's my
fairly confident prediction
if it can pause yeah then like a lot of
interesting questions come up because
like the GPT level crop of uh of AIS
that will continue improving even if you
don't do like like sort of new
generational uh experiments breathing
experiments
then
even even those or let's just could be
like super disruptive like for example I
I wouldn't wouldn't want to be an art
student uh in the year of like 2023 uh
because like
it's possible that the skills that
you're learning are somehow can be
pivoted into something that they will be
societal domain societal demand four but
the answer could also be nope there
won't be any demand for your skills I
personally see that extending to a great
many domains we just did a little
episode on the possibilities for
economic transformation and one of the
things I'm trying to kind of help people
understand is I feel like right now we
are in this
kind of perfect little happy Zone
um you could call it like the Goldilocks
time after the you know I don't know if
you know the Goldilocks uh story but
this feels like the level of AI power
that is just right perhaps in that you
know 90th percentile on the American bar
exam like that's a really strong showing
and you know that's base model
gpt4 capability right when you imagine
what that can start to power when it is
fine-tuned when it is integrated with
other systems you know when it's able to
take advantage of its ability which
we've seen demonstrated to use tools you
know and that's not yet broadly deployed
but it certainly has been I think
compellingly demonstrated then you add
on to that you know an even bigger
context window that very few have seen
and then on top of that you've got the
multimodal stuff like these these models
will the latest models will certainly be
able to like browse around the internet
and understand website sites and you
know kind of navigate and take take
actions online it feels like that is
enough on the positive side to create
transformation really economic
transformation is kind of my Baseline
scenario at this point and you know
we're just at the beginning of of kind
of the engineering phase of that the
deployment phase the like social you
know figuring out of how it's all going
to integrate and it feels like that
could be really amazing and yet at the
same time it seems like still pretty
safe to say that it's
limited enough in power that it won't
become you know an out of control
problem at this level
so
I think that is you know one of the
things that frustrates me most is when
people who focus on AI risk also dismiss
the power because I'm like you're
undermining your own message there if
you if you dismiss what it can do then
nobody's going to worry about what you
are worried about you know that it might
do so let's let's be very clear on like
just how capable the the systems are so
I like your comment about conjecture
having like the highest respect uh for
AI I think that's something I I try to
cultivate in myself as well do you see
that any differently from me like does
it does it feel to you like what we have
is enough for economic transformation or
where do you think we are on that I have
like a lot of confusion uh about like
how high economy works in the first
place because I know that there are jobs
uh whose main purpose is to make the
boss feel more important I don't think
like these jobs are very vulnerable to
AI disruption uh because boss would not
be uh Phil what would be less important
if that like uh underlink would be
replaced by AI
uh but I don't know how how we're gonna
how typical uh that kind of job is in
human economy
uh and also like psychiatrically as it
has pointed out that they just doesn't
expect any changes uh from AI before
like we all die because like the rules
and regulations uh in economy have like
uh sort of constrained everything to the
degree where you've got just I can't
have like Innovation that
is going to leave like a significant
mark on the GDP or or like have like a
big big changes in like I don't know
construction or something like that
perhaps it's wrong uh but but I just I
have like a significant uncertainty
about
definitely wouldn't be confident that
because we're gonna get uh like massive
economic disruption from the current
crop of AIS uh but it's very plausible
that that we would yes yeah I think it
what you said about
just how much time there is for the
transformation to play out definitely
makes sense to me we're on uh I've
started counting time since the official
release of gpt4 so we're at four weeks
and one day into the gpt4 era as of
today
and I do think it's really worth just
kind of reminding ourselves and grinding
ourselves in the fact that no previous
system
that the public had any access to
could really do
the sorts of high value tasks that gpt4
can just do and so we're we're literally
you know there's been a lot of growing
awareness there's been you know
interesting use cases there's been like
copywriting you know assistants that
have made a lot of money but there was
not an AI on the market until a month
ago that had any plausible chance of
like giving you quality legal advice and
or a quality medical advice and now you
know that is there and you know again
we're just so early in in starting to
figure out how to use it so it does seem
like that takes a little while kind of
unavoidably
um and I just want to remind the
listening audience more so than you like
this that window has just opened and you
know we have we have no idea what's
about to start coming through it
economically let alone uh in terms of
you know
alien AI overlords so turning then to
the kind of things that you worry about
I think this model of
AI strength kind of proceeding through
you know what appears to be a smooth
loss curve but
what actually seems to be happening
under the hood is like all these little
thresholds of unlocking different
discrete capabilities
um kind of being passed you know one by
one and all that kind of aggregating yes
I love that paper
um all that kind of aggregating to a
smooth curve but actually being like all
these little discrete bits
I think that's a really helpful frame
but I want to ask you like what are the
things that you kind of most worry about
if you could try to make this somewhat
Vivid for people what are the big
thresholds that you're like man
I don't know when but an AI crosses that
threshold and we're in real trouble like
what are those and how does that play
out in your mind
so it's possible that there are like
many uh such thresholds
uh that we should be worried about like
one kind of sort of neutral frame to
describe what AI is is that it's an
automated decision making machine that
is a non-human and B it is getting
increasingly competent by day uh so and
like whenever as every leader knows
whenever you're delegating uh something
you're also like giving up some control
over the outcome uh so uh with that
frame like there could be like many
domains uh where we in order to remain
in charge of of what happens next we
should not delegate it to non-humans
uh
so we should have like as they call it
human in the loop
uh but like the most obvious one that I
can think of uh where we are already
rushing to delegate things away is AI
development so like once you have ai
uh llms that are able to develop
AI is better than any human researchers
can
uh then basically we have this most
capable systems on this planet
appearing without any human help and
possibly without any human consultation
uh and then basically
good luck Humanity
yeah that's interesting I thought you
were maybe going to say the deception
threshold uh which is one that I hear
kind of thrown around most
I mean it's funny it's striking for one
thing that like that's kind of open ai's
explicit plan you know they're they're
fairly uh high level I would say plan
for AI alignment involves uh ultimately
having ai's kind of supervise themselves
and you know we'll find the data set and
hopefully bootstrap into something good
that has never really reassured me that
much either
um anthropic also doing something yeah
constitutional AI that is like
specificity although this is like kind
of ai's constraining AIS rather than AI
is developing uh next Generations of AIS
I think this like it's important they're
gonna distinguish between two those two
um frames one big threshold is AI
designing training the next generation
of AIS pretty hopefully intuitive to see
for people how that becomes
potentially a runaway problem that we
don't have great control over uh the
deception threshold you know kind of
outer inner alignment mismatch it seems
like one that a lot of people worry
about
just as much any
personal thoughts on that one that you
want to share yeah I think like one
thing that I and like alignment
Community has sort of like learned over
the last decade is that the shape of the
of the alignment problem has become like
much clearer like for example indeed
this like inner outer alignment uh
dichotomy is something that at least
myself that had no idea about uh just
like this idea that
deep learning Paradigm and must I would
say like machine learning Paradigm in
general is
training AIS by
picking essentially random Minds out
from behavioral classes so like you're
not selecting AIS based on what what
they want uh you're selecting AIS based
on how they behave and and like they
could like many many motivational
structures behind uh behind giving
certain particular Behavior the most
scary one is basically I realizing that
it is being trained and then just like
acting out uh the the goal that you're
training training it for in order to uh
kind of be selected and and eventually
Escape escape the Box
yeah I think that one is hard to get
around to just from the simple
observation that
we're not super reliable you know
anybody who spent a significant amount
of time trying to validate language
model output even just for like a you
know relatively run-of-the-mill
application like I've done this at
waymark right we're making
marketing video content for small
businesses and you know really all the
stuff we create is from with language
models the main thing is write a script
for a like short commercial for a small
business so it's a pretty narrow domain
of of space that we need to evaluate and
yet it remains a real challenge to
figure out like is this model better
than this one or you know we do a fine
tune how does it compare to the last
fine tune you know you're getting all
these like different outputs and
It's just tough like the over the
distributions are overlapping you know
the the the rate at which the new model
is preferred to the previous one is
often fairly low I've seen published
results as low as like 11 to 9 ratio you
know where where one is preferred to the
other even gbt4 to 3.5 is just 70 30. in
terms of preference so like still a full
third of the time people prefer 3.5 in a
head-to-head comparison which kind of
blows my mind given how like
qualitatively better it seems gpt4 is so
that's just like the general problem of
of validation but then you add into that
mix that like we have all these you know
heuristics and biases that are
exploitable we have these kind of you
know cognitive uh gaps that have kind of
lingered in our our own systems and you
know Evolution never had a had a real
reason to eliminate all of them or
Greener never hasn't got around to it
yet
um and so we're exploitable right and
we're everybody kind of know is that in
our daily life like we know that people
at a minimum will tell us like little
white lies to make us feel good or just
to get through a situation a little bit
easier do you see any promising route to
avoiding that sort of
exploitable evaluator
um
problem uh I mean short answer is no
uh but it's uh it's like very much like
open research question sort of on a
theoretical level indeed you would want
to somehow kind of hit your right on the
increasing capabilities of AI uh when it
comes to
um when it comes to somehow making it
more reliable or more constrained uh
more predictable in general I hesitate
to say more aligned because like my
mother goes like oh no no you don't you
don't point point AI towards alignment
that's just like a silly thing to do
so uh but yeah like like AIS are going
going to get more capable
can be somehow
get something out of it that is scalable
rather than kind of ending in in a
predictably bad place
it might be worth just spending a little
bit more time too on again just kind of
how these things might play out I think
Elias are spoken very
interestingly compellingly about what
happens when you go outside of your
distribution of training and for humans
he just points out that you know
basically everything in nature is
optimized for reproduction in you know
inclusive genetic fitness
and yet the behavior that we observe in
ourselves is not at all about in the
modern environment does not appear to be
about maximizing our reproduction and in
fact we didn't even know that that's
what we had been optimized for until
relatively recently so we were out here
kind of doing whatever we're doing
um it took like a few random Geniuses to
figure out how we had actually kind of
been created by nature and that has had
relatively little impact on what anyone
has actually done in their day-to-day uh
live so would you um would you add
anything to that uh that story or
observation yeah I mean just to be more
precise I think we are selected uh for
uh
for uh kind of inclusive genetic fitness
ability to reproduce uh and uh
again because of the same
problem that machine learning faces that
that we can only select based on
Behavior Uh or based on results uh
that selection kind of effectively pulls
in like a random random instantiation
of capabilities and and motivations that
just happened to give you this
particular Behavior without having any
fine fine-grained control over over what
these motivations and capabilities
actually are so yes like uh we ended up
Evolution ended up pulling us
selecting Us in this like ancestral
environment where we had developed as a
bunch of heuristics that were very
useful uh for for reproduction in that
ancestral environment but much less so
uh in in the modern environment without
like never
actually uh actually kind of ingraining
uh in US any fundamental understanding
uh what were being selected for so I I
the very same process might just replay
it when it comes very same process might
get replayed as we are selecting AIS
based on behavior and without without
any insight on the inner workings of
them
so we could spend hours uh unpacking all
this and I know you have done that you
know many times so maybe we'll bracket
that for the moment we've got all these
different failure modes we've got you
know potentially kind of runaway AI
training its own successors in a way
that is not clear to us we've got kind
of the deception problem we've got the
fact that we have no reassurance or no
reason to believe really at all that the
goals that we have for AI will be like
represented internally
um and so you know with
a sudden jump in kind of the domain in
which the AI can operate you know it can
be totally outside of of training
distribution and you know who knows how
it might act you know just like who
would have expected how humans uh might
have acted from you know the ancestral
environment
so all these things are you know pretty
big conceptual problems
we don't have good answers to them at
the moment
what do you think that kind of how does
that boil down to a
a simple world view for you like what
are the odds that you see right now of
serious catastrophe happening in say the
next two five ten years
um and maybe we could segment that into
given the trajectory that we're on
versus like what how we might be able to
shift that
um if for example we've you know took a
pause yeah my current estimate for for
kind of life-fending disaster is
basically one to fifty percent per
generation uh of uh per like 10 next Inc
of compute that's being thrown at these
experiments
so uh and like current that they are
10xing things in like six to eighteen
months uh window so you can kind of
calculate from there I mean at some
point we're going to run out of compute
uh because like there's only so many so
many 10x thing you can do so you can't
like
maybe probably count to like thousands
of thousands of those uh but still like
uh
uh let's say something like a geometric
mean of one and fifty percent is is
seven percent so by seven percent risk
to everything
uh like uh if you continue doing those
we probably can still do like something
like five or six of those
and at that point they're like more
likely dead than not
worth taking a second to just let that
sink in
would you have put that same estimate on
gpt4
like do you think we just survived a
seven percent
X risk event with the training of gbt4
that is a great question like with like
hindsight is like I'm like super
anchored now right uh
so I really want to say no but uh but
again like that that range is like like
seven percent is like this point
estimate but uh but like I I really my
uncertain range is like from one uh to
fifty percent and like so it's a very
interesting question is like would I put
like less than one percent
uh confidence in in GPT not destroying
everything gbt4 not destroying
everything and probably not so I think
yeah it's I think it's unreasonable to
to kind of have at least the thing given
the things that are new uh were GPT free
uh and like everything else uh and like
things that I didn't know uh like having
a very close look at what's what's
happening at gpd4 uh in GPT for training
then yeah I think it's it would have
been unreasonable for me to be less than
one percent
like confident in less than one percent
uh
Doom from gpt4 honestly I can't really
argue with you there when I look at the
you know when I got my first look at it
it had already finished pre-training and
initial reinforcement learning
um and this was you know the six months
ago when they kind of finished the first
version before any of the safety work
and obviously there was the you know the
whole red teaming effort and and
everything else
um it definitely hit me pretty hard but
like wow this is a significant leap and
now you look at all the papers that have
kind of come out characterizing it
in the wake of the the official release
the thing that I kind of keep coming
back to is we have these smooth curves
but then you have on individual
behaviors you have these sudden jumps so
the one they published in the in the
technical report which isn't such a big
deal obviously uh but maybe you know
indicative of things that could happen
in the future on on more problematic
Dimensions is the hindsight bias uh
failure where it had previously been
observed I think by anthropic that
bigger models suffered more from
hindsight bias and so it was an example
of a you know an inverse scaling law
where the behavior is getting worse with
bigger models and then all of a sudden
with gbt4
that problem is totally fixed and there
is no Han's hindsight bias and it
basically just scores like 100 you know
Perfection on those hindsight bias
problems which by the way are basically
like scenarios where you had a good bet
available to you you like took the good
bet and you lost you know in an unlikely
way
um and so the question then is like you
know should you have taken the BET and
you you know people might say in the
hindsight buyers would be well no if I
lost then I shouldn't have done it when
in reality like you actually had you
know all good reasons to do it
um so 3.5 you know was actually getting
this wrong more often than like three
and more often than some smaller models
but then again boom some somehow some
unlock has happened in the course of
training
um and it was probably never registered
on the smooth loss curve uh which you
know mostly looks smooth
but
all of a sudden this Behavior now is
like totally strong I would say you know
probably safe safe to say superhuman in
the sense that obviously we create these
measures because some of us struggle
with the hindsight bias and so yeah you
wonder okay if that's those kinds of
things we do see those kind of sudden
jumps in capability
um in the context of gbd4 like
you know another 10 50 100x compute
scale up
um you know it's predictable that it
will bring more of them
but it's very unclear like what exactly
they would be
so
one to fifty percent across these you
know big scale-up training runs how do
you think that plays out across
different groups that might be running
those processes
um I don't know if you may or may not
want to go you know to kind of specific
names but like obviously there's a few
leading groups that can plausibly scale
up another you know one or two orders of
magnitude right now
do you think that's like equally
Reckless for any of them to do or do you
think some have a better handle on how
to do that responsibly than others I
mean they're always like some
differences in various dimensions
[Music]
so
yeah I mean just like hanging out in
anthropic uh feels materially different
uh than hanging out in Deep Mind uh
where I both hanged out
both places and like a little bit that
open AI so like they're sitting like a
much more safety culture uh in in
anthropic does that justify risking
everything
like killing everyone is like I don't
think so uh so it's like in some ways
these are like second order it might be
they're like second order effects how
how
whole kind of like safety crunches uh
your groupies uh compared to the fact
that you're taking just massive risks uh
with everyone's lives right now so how
do you think about you've been you
mentioned two companies that I have
serious questions about I guess let's go
deep mine first
I've been kind of waiting for like a
gato to
to drop and it seems like you know as I
check my my imaginary watch like it
seems like that is probably due right
around now unless there's
some sort of pause or like somebody's
kind of thought better of doing a gato 2
or you know maybe it just didn't work
for some reason but that seems unlikely
because it seems like almost everything
is you know quote unquote working these
days
um
do you have a sense for like what is
going on at deepmind you know Demis um
published a Time article it feels like a
long time ago much more uh you know
reserved in uh moderated tone for a Time
article than than Elias's more recent
one but still pretty striking to see
founder CEO of deepmind saying you know
we need to think about slowing down are
they slowing down I mean I don't know I
don't have like that much visibility uh
into deep mind uh I have heard about
them deliberately being more cautious
about the publishing
things uh which is our empirical I think
that I haven't verified is that actually
true but it feels that that they are
more careful now when it comes to
publishing
in some ways we're kind of in a lucky
world uh that uh
like I mean all all the
big free labs they are safety conscious
to the level at least the level of not
dismissing the risks in a way that for
example young lacun Randy Arc just
completed this missing the risks it's
not obvious that we that the world
should be in a way in a way that like
for example I mean I've been praising
Sam Altman for for saying saying the
things that he says about about the
risks and he's been very explicit about
massive dangers that humanity is facing
from AI
uh so so like another question is like
like to what degree does this safety
Consciousness actually kind of constrain
the actions of these companies that have
their own incentives as like non-human
uh optimization engines
uh and uh and like necessarily some hard
to
hard to lead like I mean the leaders of
AI companies uh they they have like a
bunch of conflicting
requirements that they want to satisfy
especially in like in deepmind where
it's like one big constraint is that
they're not a company they're like like
a subsidiary of uh of of Google uh so
it's uh like I in some ways I'm kind of
sympathetic uh to them trying to trying
to navigate uh like that must be complex
uh set of constraints
uh and uh I think you're right yeah I
found myself saying this too like it is
easy to imagine people that are a lot
more Cavalier you know running the um
Frontier projects so I'm I'm thankful
that there does seem to be
a profound like awareness and you know
real seriousness of approach across the
the biggest companies
in some ways I also feel like we might
be in a lucky scenario in that language
models are taking off and yet they're
very like
kind of soft and edged AI
um they kind of also run slow
and I contrast that to what you know I
think maybe Elias are sort of had a nine
14 years ago or what deepmind was you
know
seemingly like closest to if I had to
say you know five years ago who was
closest to AJ I would have said deepmind
with all of their like you know game
playing you know agent learning agents
all that kind of stuff
um those notably like
achieve drum you know like Alpha zero
and all that right they notably achieve
like dramatically superhuman performance
in obviously like narrow domains
um they also run really fast
and they're trained if anything in like
an even more
alien way where Alpha zero just plays
itself right in in all these games and
kind of learns from that and doesn't
even need to see the database of human
games and and therefore it when it shows
up with superhuman uh skill it's also
like kind of an alien superhuman skill
and you get these like dramatically
surprising moves that you know no human
would ever have made in contrast I feel
like language models
you know everything has pros and cons
right they certainly have insane surface
area
but they're kind of
softness and slowness does seem like it
might
um be a real Advantage relative to a
more kind of hardened you know faster
agent type of model
how do you think about that do you think
we are lucky with llms or am I just
naive in my optimism yeah I think like
the big trend has been negative in terms
of like going towards more and more
black boxy and kind of uncontrollable
training regimes uh like going from like
expert system to supervise to
unsupervised learning on the other hand
yeah there are a few things definitely
to that tattoo you can sort of cut got
lucky with uh like one of like the I
would say the prime one is is the fact
that you actually do need a lot of
compute uh to do the pre-training uh of
large language models which means that
there are only like
number small number of organizations on
the planet who can do that and like
those training runs are
potentially very
conspicus so
like uh only half joking to say that
like the planet is now breeding alien
mines in a way that aliens can see
because like very plausibly you can see
those energy expenditures from space
uh so like that's like one lucky thing
about telems and the other thing yeah I
agree that the the speed
uh twitch on the slowness rather uh at
which taking off like uh process uh
things is uh he's an adult net Advantage
uh but this is a temporary Advantage I'm
pretty sure uh because like uh human
Minds human brains themselves are like
offer like a concept
uh proof of concept that like no he's
not had to be that slow this is like
just like pure inefficiency
yeah like once you have like some kind
of feedback process where the
like llms will start developing AIS uh
those AIS might not might no longer be
llms
what do you make of this current moment
and this is something that has really
just popped up and gone kind of
widespread
in just the last two weeks but there's
all these kind of projects to create you
know some one of them is called Baby AGI
another is called Auto GPT and
essentially they're taking a language
model putting it in a loop and kind of
giving it you know the ability to like
have a goal you know delegate to itself
go through these like thinking reasoning
planning steps you know then start to
use tools
um and again like you know getting
around the kind of hard limit of a
context window through some sort of
self-delegation
I'm struck by that as kind of you know
potentially the next convergence between
those two paradigms in some ways and it
also seems to
open up the potential for
a kind of Auto you know self-play
reinforcement learning like these agents
are not very good right now and so if
you go on Twitter you'll see people
being like this is so amazing look what
this thing can do and then you'll see
other people being like it fails way too
much these are not useful it's going to
be a long time before they are useful
but I kind of think those people are
wrong in the sense that
this is the first language model
Paradigm that feels like relatively easy
to evaluate in a fairly open domain
because you can kind of know like did
the thing you know book you the flight
or whatever right or did it just get
hung up on some API error that it never
solved and it seems like they're gonna
learn pretty quick from this like
massive little agentization and you know
kind of exploring uh Paradigm that's
just been set up like how worrying of a
development is that for you
select several frames to look at this
thing and and these frames will kind of
like give you is almost a very kind of
opposing uh judgment about the situation
for example one very positive frame to
look at this is that that like it's
great that uh Society is like kind of
like poking uh kind of rattling and
poking uh these current models uh to see
like uh what are the extremes that you
can push them to because like they are
not very competent and like by having
those uh kind of experiments with like
chaos GPT and whatnot we will we as a
civilization will actually learn like
how bad things could be if if things uh
would be scaled up so if you take like
chaos CPT and then put like gpt6 I claim
you
might not be safe at all anymore on the
other hand like you can take this Frame
that that like when I don't know people
like yandakun Etc have been saying like
like there's nothing to worry about from
AI because like it's not gonna be agent
and even if it's going to be agent like
it would be just stupid uh to uh kind of
install some like self-preservation and
and uh and just kind of like bad goals
like women we're not going to do that
it's like no we absolutely are like a
fraction of humanity has a death wish so
it's it's like uh it's it's that is like
enough
clear empirical demonstrations that like
if something really bad can be done with
AI it will be done yeah it's a big world
and uh it's pretty easy I mean that's
the other thing that's amazing like I
think the first commit of the baby AGI
project which I believe has been the
number one trending project on GitHub
over the last couple weeks alongside
like a couple other very similar
projects
um the first commit I think was 105
lines of code
and that's all it takes you know a
couple clever prompts and you know and
kind of a loop and you've got yourself a
Moodle agent you know and it might not
do much yet
um but the bear given the model the
barrier to you know creating some sort
of
semi-embodied you know autonomous
version of that is proving to be
extremely low
so yeah I don't think we're gonna we
will not be able to rely on the good uh
discretion of users in the long term uh
certainly probably not more more than uh
for a few days with the release of any
major new system
you mentioned a minute ago you said
three kind of leading groups and I
wanted to ask you
how you think about like who is at the
frontier and who is maybe going to
be at the frontier over the next few
years I assume the three you had in mind
you didn't specifically say open AI but
obviously they're in that group deepmind
was the other that we were discussing
and then I I I'm guessing you're
thinking anthropic would be uh the third
I think deep behind on Google they're
gonna have like could be kind of
interchangeable uh I kind of hear that
they are gonna
female publicly mentioned that like
they're somehow kind of joining forces
when it comes to this Ella lamp race so
nobody else you feel like is close
enough at this point like if it's a
coordination problem of who actually you
know who are you calling on to pause I
mean you're calling on everyone to pause
but it sounds like it's really those
three organizations that you're calling
on for a pause yeah I think they're like
the first so-called like first tier when
it comes to doing like the most
dangerous experiments but like of course
then you have like the second tier I
think Eleazar has this uh kind of relate
that law like the Moore's Law of mad
science uh that uh
I can't forget exactly how it was framed
it was like a memory every every two
years that the uh IQ needed to destroy
the world uh drops by like one or two
points so it's uh as the
Hardware companies uh
mostly Nvidia at this point will throw
you more and more capable
and cheap Computing Cycles uh at the
market the world destroying capability
will be in in a larger number of hands
interesting to think about how that
evolves over the next few years do you
think if you imagine that let's say we
do enact a pause
and then you know meanwhile Nvidia keeps
shipping and people keep kind of doing
you know fundamental which notably the
letter
explicitly goes out of its way to say
like we're not saying all AI research
should stop or that you know you can't
build your small models or fine-tune
things for your use cases and so on
um so if we imagine a world where there
is kind of a pause on these high-end
experiments
but Hardware continues to ship and
generally speaking like the field is not
shut down
do you have a guess for how many
folks would be in the kind of
you know would be able to do a gpt5 type
project if they chose to in say five
years
my fiber is a super long time uh yeah
I'm with you on that by the way I don't
even try to guess things five years out
so I shouldn't ask yeah two years I mean
yeah probably a dozen
um it's something that kind of like it's
just pull out of thin air uh if I would
think about it then I would probably
have like a I mean it's probably less
than 100 uh more than 10 uh perhaps
closer to ten than 10 to 100 is my
answer in two years and so some of those
we can kind of fill in
pretty obviously right like meta seems
like it would be a very natural
candidate
um Microsoft I mean they have the open
AI partnership but they certainly also
have their own big research division
um presumably Apple you know has the
resources to get into that game
maybe even like a Tesla I mean they're
focused on other things at the moment
seemingly but they also have the bot you
know the Tesla bot is going to need uh
some sort of
you know fairly general intelligence to
to help it walk around and talk to
people and pick stuff up
any other kind of
specific actors that you think would be
likely entrance there and then how do
you think about kind of the
international scene like is there
anything coming out of Europe and
obviously then everybody starts to think
about
China too yeah I was going to say that
like the obvious like in two-year
perspective yeah you should kind of like
uh start also like
uh looking at like non-us actors uh
in Europe where it's gonna yeah compute
is much more available uh and then also
China uh I think they're like
one sort of
obvious counter argument that we're
getting with uh when it comes to like
calling for the pause is that like what
about China uh and uh like my answer
there is that
like currently China does not seem to be
in the race at least not as intensely in
as uh the leading us labs are in a race
between themselves
and second like sort of almost like
culturally uh Chinese seem to be like
much less keen on pulling a bing uh and
and just like on unleashing uh
uncontrollable mind on their territory
uh I mean only half joking you say that
like in China if you do that as a tech
CEO that might get to disappeared but
yeah in in the
longer run of like two or more years
it is Big will become like more and more
important to get some kind of
international uh agreement that we
already have in nuclear for example in
place for also for compute
on the China front I totally agree it's
like I don't know why we would assume
given the posture that the Chinese
government has taken to our technology
over the last few years that this is the
technology that they're just gonna throw
caution to the wind on right I mean
they've shut down functionally shut down
their entire video game industry and
limited it to as I understand it just
like a few hours on like a couple
weekend nights per week is like all that
like video game companies I think can
even operate in China now we should fact
check me on that but that's what I
understand to be the case an online
online learning I understand this also
uh being mostly and I that one is is
fascinating too because like who could
object to online learning but my sense
is that they intervene their
on like a state level because they feel
like there is an unhealthy Market
Dynamic developing where people are like
working too hard on these you know yeah
on these like whatever standardized test
measures and like putting way too much
resources in this and it's like gone
past the point of like societal benefit
yeah I mean I I I'm actually a chairman
of a language
online language teaching company uh
Estonian company that has like big
linguist this oh yeah you know it of
course and uh and like one thing that
they learned in Japanese Market is that
there's like a massive English teaching
Market in Japan but people aren't caring
don't care about learning the language
they just want to pass the tests in
order to get like better employment
options so like like you're not like
this is like as a language teaching
company in Japan your job is not to
teach the language your job is to get
people past a good get good test scores
which are very different job so I say
suspect that something like that was
also happened in China I would not take
personally I'm not ready to uh Say by
any means that I want to you know fully
subscribe to uh Xi Jinping thought or
live under the technology regime there
but it does seem like we're jumping to a
conclusion
way too quickly uh when we say like well
if we don't do it they will and you know
that'll be worse but leaving that aside
for a second just coming back to
ourselves
the other big thing that has come out
this last week or so is apparent and I I
take that it's probably legitimate a
sort of leaked uh fundraising document
from anthropic that says that they are
planning to raise five or so billion
dollars and
kind of see the next two three years as
like super critical
um planning to do like next-gen models
you know they're kind of immediately
moving into a gpt5 you know type uh
scaling regime it sounds like the model
itself you know supposedly is going to
cost like a billion dollars to train and
then they say
um again this is all according to
reporting I haven't seen the deck but
those that fall behind in the 25-26 time
frame may never be able to catch up
so when I heard that I was like man that
does not sound like a company that's
about to pause
um it doesn't sound like
I mean it does sound like a company
that's kind of in the race now
um how are you viewing that news and I
don't know if you have any you know
inside view I don't obviously wouldn't
ask you to um you know to share anything
that you shouldn't but
what should the public make of that that
you know update from
supposedly like the most safety Centric
leading lab that there is yeah I mean
like to that to that degree that this
thing was accurate which again I can't
comment on uh because I'm investor in an
Tropic and portal Board of server as
well I think to the degree that it was
accurate it is
strong evidence that there is like a
massive race happening between the US
companies that is going to get us killed
so like can we stop that race please
what exactly is the thought process
knowing that this group came from open
AI they you know high level description
that I've heard is you know they felt
like it was becoming too commercial they
wanted to be more focused on a safety
first type of approach
and that's been you know two years or
whatever
now this like what the only thing I can
come up with is people must be thinking
we'll do a better job than they will do
so therefore we should do it before they
do it because if we don't then they'll
do it they'll do it worse
um and it seems like maybe everybody's
thinking that I kind of model like open
AI to some degree
that way as well
is that how you think about the decision
makers or what do you think they're
thinking so I think like one very
informative uh public uh piece of
information is like future flight
Institute podcast with Dario and Daniela
uh that was like during covet
about a year ago um like yeah in early
early 22.
well basically kind of like uh they
explain like what the approach of
anthropic is and as far as I know it is
uh it is true what what I said in that
in this podcast is basically like train
the frontier models uh and then
basically do alignment in an empirical
fashion while having access to Frontier
models and the claim is that it is
exactly because of this emergent
capabilities there is only so much you
can do uh using uh sort of not state of
the art
models because uh in some ways
as the models get more competent they
also become easier to interact with and
like I mean just the fact that we have
language models in the first place like
that is in some ways I think you pointed
it out this is uh
I can also like serve as a good
interface when it comes to alignment so
like yeah that is kind of an tropics
or Tropics thesis uh to be to have like
this uh latest models
and and then basically use those to to
like state of the art uh alignment uh
that is kind of like empirically tied to
actual objects that we have now of
course the big question there is like
how many generations you can do that for
like uh like because like the
pre-training is like largely
uncontrolled unsupervised process like
how many
Generations uh we can do the
pre-training safely not to mention
things like leaks to elsewhere of the of
the resulting weights uh so like I think
it's like genuine dilemma it's it's uh
in some ways I think anthropics
Framing and perspective makes a lot of
sense because indeed like the largest
line like the
you can do more get more useful
alignment work done with the latest
crop of the of the large language models
on the other hand like each training
imposes like some risk again in my
estimate one to fifty percent risk of
complete annihilation of the planet
how do you navigate that trade-off it's
it's not obvious and I don't think
that's current
enough kind of thinking into into uh
into that trade-off
again it feels like there's some sort of
you know Game Theory element here where
it's like
it seems like they're doing it because
they believe someone else is doing it
still on some level right if they if
they roughly share your view and they're
like well the only way we can do the
alignment work is if we have access to
the latest models
then a good counter argument would be if
it were true well nobody else is going
to create these if you don't so maybe
you should just sit tight too and then
we can all kind of you know study what
we have we don't need another Frontier
just yet
so it still seems like it is fair to say
there that like on some level they feel
like their hand is forced like they
can't not do it because they're either
in the game or they're out of the game
but the game will continue regardless it
seems to be the the model that's kind of
implicit in that decision making
yeah I mean like a few models that are
sort of consistent with evidence but
that definitely is uh like one model
because of like this race pressures
they're gonna feel that like if they
don't have access to the latest
uh generation of models they like can
the prospects of actually doing
alignment are significantly hampered so
that's like the positive way of offering
things
the letter even like I think explicit to
mentioned that uh one goal of this
letter is to like call for this timeout
in this race that indeed has like
non-trivial game theoretic uh element I
think your most recent kind of
fundamental AI research investment is in
conjecture
and if I understand correctly I may be
wrong on this but I don't get the sense
that they are planning to like try to
train a gpt5 in the short term how are
you thinking about kind of their
contribution their strategy it seems
like they take a different approach
where they they don't feel like they
have to create the frontier models in
order to do something useful yeah I am
much more positive uh about conjectures
approach uh in terms of like safety
capabilities uh trade-off uh they still
train language models but they do not do
like enough latest language models their
goal is to kind of like uh
compose
less capable
language models uh in a way that kind of
makes a more makes for a more
predictable structure so you're like you
don't risk the world during the
pre-training phase and have like a more
he's always kind of more old-school
approach to AI rather than this uh
summon and tame approach yeah
interesting we just did an episode with
um Andreas and jungwon from art and they
have a very similar you know kind of
Outlook too
composition of models you know the sort
of traceability of all the logic you
know atomization of the different
decisions and operations to try to
create you know some sense of kind of
designed to control you know into the
system from the beginning uh sounds like
conjecture is kind of on a similar line
of thinking yep and I think like they
managed to get the pulse uh in this like
game theoretic race
um
assuming there's a game theoretic race
it does also like some frame that says
that no this is like uh just apocalyptic
test cards uh trying to enter World uh
this is like the least least charitable
frame uh but uh if you could get a pause
uh then like uh I do think that like
there's like this
like almost automatic pressure to get
like more competence out of the mines
that we already have trained
and part of it is just like to have like
a better understanding a better
composition uh of the capabilities that
we already have because like one
important bit like as
a lot of your listeners probably know is
that you have like this training phase
uh that is like much much more expensive
than actually the inference phrase so
like once you have like spent a lot of
compute and training
once you finish the training you have a
lot of ability to run many many uh
instances of the of the mindset you just
just trained so let's talk about them
later so you guys obviously we've you
know we've covered a decade of your uh
thinking and investment on this subject
and now we get to the point where okay
gpt4 is released it is
you know closing in on human expert
performance in a great many domains it
does seem to me like
it's quite
unclear like what the next generation of
that would bring obviously you guys are
thinking you know something
um very similar there
so how did this project come about for a
letter like how did you guys settle on a
six-month pause how what was the process
like of like trying to bring a broad
Coalition together and was this
something that you guys like actually
thought might happen or you know is it
is it kind of a intended to be a
conversation starter like how do you
think about this project
good questions
I remember we had like
fli catch up call on
March 21st so I mean less than a month
ago
and uh we were kind of like we had
already observed that they're like
significant voices uh like in in the
public I mean the Castle Rock clients
article in New York Times had come come
out where he
kind of
explicitly
compared the current AI race to like
summoning
summoning mines
and I think harare's article also was
published around that time where he kind
of was concerned about llms plugging
into into the operating system of
civilization which is like about
language
and which operates on the language level
uh so uh until like numerous discussions
uh sort of private discussions that are
very concerned uh about uh
about the current race including with
people in the labs themselves uh so we
thought that okay
perhaps like one valuable thing that I
feel like could do uh is to try to
create some kind of common knowledge
that yes like a bunch of people are
worried and uh basically
create a situation where like those
people know that other people are also
uh worried and and the other people know
that that the other people know Etc and
we thought okay we have some experience
with uh with
um open letters so perhaps we should
like try to draft draft or not and of
course like our previous open letters
had something like 1000 or less less
than thousand signatures so like one
thing that we got just gone completely
blown away by uh was was just a reaction
uh like gonna meet that in the first few
days we got like tens of thousands of
signatures uh and we had like technical
problems because of that so yeah like
the when it came to kind of drafting the
the letter uh there were like multiple
considerations like one consideration
was just speed so like clearly if we
would have had like uh several weeks to
work on it uh then uh
would that be much better uh but like it
was like sort of done much in the spirit
of like not let's let's not have the
perfect to be the enemy of the good and
and let's start off something that that
feels
uh okay to put out uh indeed like the
six month number was like one thing that
kind of uh was put in and then put I
taken back out of uh from different
versions of the draft uh and uh
argument find out that kind of one
nowhere the six month thing was that
like
one question we get like so like why six
months why what can you
deal with a six month what can it
demonstrate with a six what would six
months pause buy us like one one
important thing that people don't
necessarily realize that's a six month
pause would buy us is is confidence that
we can pause
and so and like in that that sense it's
uh it's
better to have a proposal that calls for
six month post to fail
than a proposal that calls for
indefinite pause to fail because like
the indefinite post situation people are
going oh yeah if it would have been six
months of course we could have could
have done it but like because indefinite
like nobody would pause indefinitely
right so that was like the final final
kind of like reason that we thought okay
let's let's put in six months and see
what happens yeah I thought uh zv had
some great analysis of this in the first
uh somebody who also works with a speed
premium that I appreciate
um had some just I felt pretty
ultimately simple but but still very
wise analysis that's just like
if you want if you feel like you're
going to need coordination in the future
it makes sense to start building it now
and if you need if you you know can only
get a little bit going at first then you
kind of take what you can get and you
hope to build on that Foundation yeah
the other kind of like really big uh
considerations that can fit into the
open letter is that like there's a lot
of reasonable discussion uh
that happens like in the labs and even
between the racing Labs uh about the
need to kind of like coordinate the need
to pause need to be careful and like
people have become public about it Etc
but like there's like oh there's like
one missing component
the component is like when
they like they always say I think Scott
Alexander wrote a good article about uh
about dopen AIS like AGI and Beyond uh
statement where he can also pointed out
that like yeah they're saying a lot of
nice things which is great I mean
honestly it's good but they don't say
when and like this is to make a little
bit suspicious at least and so that
therefore like that one of the
rationales for the letter is that
how about now
so what if I want to go through some
additional kind of
questions that I've seen floating around
in the discourse but
what is your sense of kind of how the
reaction has been obviously there's been
a ton of signatures even one notable CEO
of you know a company that I would say
is like close to a leading lab which is
a mod from stability uh signed onto it
I thought that was fascinating
as far as I know it's been pretty quiet
reaction from
the kind of three main groups you know
that
are the ones who are going to either
pause or not pause you know for
something Beyond gpt4 so what do you
make of the reaction from them like has
there been any there's been no public
statements as far as I know and has
there been any kind of private or you
know sort of confidential reassurance
have you I mean has there been any
reaction from the the leading labs
yeah I mean I I think like some alphan
like said publicly that like he's uh
kind of like with the spirit uh of the
of the letter uh like appreciates the
spirit of the letter or something but
then there was of course a butt I don't
even remember what about exactly was
uh but yeah like a dick mine definitely
hasn't said anything uh nor has a Tropic
although like a just today red uh Chuck
Clark's uh newsletter uh import AI uh
where he kind of like mentions the
letter and also says like why he didn't
mention it last week
um
so uh story takes like some uh some
reactions but like uh
also I kind of like want to be careful
here in the sense that I don't want to
like create some self-fulfilling
prophecies uh I would say that
the possibilities are definitely very
much open at this stage uh for for the
letter somehow catalyzing uh an actual
pause uh but it's like double digit
uncertainties both ways cool that's
actually more positive of a response
albeit minimal than
um
than I had expected or even understood I
haven't seen that um Altman tweet I'll
have to dig into that and yeah I don't
think it was a tweet I think I hope I'm
not just like uh he didn't say it in my
dreams or something uh but I think it
was actually a comment in some news
article uh about uh uh about the letter
humans too suffer from hallucination at
times so we'll fact check ourselves
indeed we do so okay so we you guys put
this out there now people start to say
all kinds of stuff right
um the thing that I think is kind of
most like you didn't finish reading the
letter uh but which is definitely worth
giving you a chance to to kind of
respond to is well all the letter says
is a pause you know it doesn't ask for
anything else so it's stupid because
like what are we supposed to do again
like you can read the letter for
yourself there are definitely some
things that it calls for but just kind
of obviously it's a big tent you know
committee sort of document just zeroing
in on your own you know priorities what
do you think are like the most important
tangible concrete things that we could
do over say a six-month time frame such
that maybe even you would be comfortable
you know ending the pause like do you
I guess top priorities and if those top
priorities happened
would that be enough in your mind to
then end the pause and like trade a gpd5
so so one thing that will sort of like
happen automatically is that we will get
more experience with a crazy situation
now that we're in uh which is that we
have uh I think I think Joshua Benja uh
put it on your ShopinJA put it uh that
now we have AIS out there in the
internet that can pass a Turing test
and that is another situation uh like
and I think we are would be much smarter
six months from now than we are now
because six months will be a long period
long long chunk of time uh when it comes
to living with aliens on on your planet
so like uh I don't know what we're gonna
learn but hopefully we just like are
smarter uh in the in the Autumn than we
are in the spring
but like when it comes to like more
concrete things yeah there's like uh
I mean Neil Nanda a researcher in UK who
has worked with deepind as well as
anthropic
has this
blog post called 200 open problems in
mechanistic interpretability
so like there's like so much work that
can be done with even like the previous
generation of of models uh not to say
anything about uh about the latest
generation uh so there's like so much
kind of alignment work and uh just
opening up those black boxes and trying
to understand what makes them tick how
can we
how can we get any guarantees about what
what the next generation is going to do
so again
with research and with kind of lived
experience I hope it would have been
much better I mean I hope it would have
been much better but like realistically
I just say that we're going to be in a
better place uh six months from now that
doesn't sound to me like you would
expect just on General kind of
improvement to get to a point where you
would then say
okay let's end the pause and do the next
generation is there anything I mean
correct me if I'm wrong on that but
maybe framing the question slightly
differently if we abstracted away from
the six month time frame and said like
are there concrete
structures of some sort that we could
put in place that would on any timeline
you know kind of give you
enough confidence or reassurance that
again you can say like okay it seems
like we could we're now in a decent
enough place that you would personally
be comfortable going ahead with a
a Next Generation training I still like
the big question is like how much risk
are we okay uh taking and I'm not saying
this risk should be zero because there
is always like this background risk of
extension risk we could be hit by
asteroid there's a certain probability
that like this call will not end because
the plant will be hit uh by by like some
probably not an asteroid because we can
see this kind but by uh by Comet uh that
that is kind of harder to see I
understand
uh so like we shouldn't get the risk to
zero
um but like perhaps there are
like if there's this
pause and like associate that
realization that like these experiments
are considered like too Reckless by
Society
hopefully we will get this will create
some kind of incentive uh gradient for
the companies themselves uh to figure
out how to make them in a more
responsible Manner and more legible
manner uh so I am like I'm interested
project
in Arc alignment Research Center uh in
Berkeley uh led by Paul Cristiano called
evals like evaluating uh models uh about
like what what are the things uh that
that they could in principle do are the
things that that they're still going to
be incompetent on
when you can have like multiple opinions
about this but uh or different opinions
about this but like uh there's like a
generalization of this like is it
possible to replace the current blind as
far as I know training runs with
something that you like at every
iteration you do some tests uh that
would give you some kind of guarantees
uh about uh about the alien that you're
summoning
yeah there's a few other things that I I
think give me a little bit of
um hope that they might be developed on
a kind of a technical level during that
time there was an interesting paper that
came out from I think this is a pretty
small scale yeah I believe it was
advanthropic where they experimented
with doing the pre-training on a human
preference data set from the beginning
as opposed to just kind of you know
random
decent quality text off the internet
and it seemed that the upshot of that
was that
you never had quite as alien of an alien
in the first place you know on measures
of like
harmfulness you know for example
helpfulness
um it it stayed much closer throughout
the training process to kind of that
final post rlhf or RL aif state that we
know now and never kind of dipped as far
into
the sort of you know just very strange
alien territory of
of General pre-training
um so something like that kind of
changing the the data set maybe from the
get-go seems interesting
um another recent thing that jumped out
to me was
somebody just I think in the last week
or two just published a a result where
they showed that they were able to
increase the size of the model
progressively throughout training uh it
was kind of presented to me as like a
efficiency thing that does go to show
all these things are kind of pros and
cons you know everything is dual use but
the net savings on the training flops
was like 50 which is obviously
significant enough for people to take
notice you know even for just purely
commercial reasons but then it seemed to
me like boy there's something really
interesting there where you're creating
kind of this
seed you know kernel like truly a little
baby version of the the model that is
actually just a lot smaller in terms of
its parameters and then you're able to
kind of layer on more and more layers
parameters you know as you go through
the the whole training process it seems
like maybe there would be a way to you
know zoom in on that small thing and get
get something kind of working right in
like the small you know
presumably much more interpretable
version first before you know growing
the model itself and kind of just having
one big you know Tangled knot of of
parameters I guarantee that it will not
guarantee uh like safety in the long run
but it might just be enough to reduce
the probability of destroying everything
in the Next Generation so we can
actually kind of like do one more step
uh in a way that is much more
responsible than the current default so
one thing that you have not gone to
much here is
regulation government intervention I
mean the letter does call for that if
there's if there can be no pause then
government should step in and insist on
one but you're not putting a lot of you
know maybe you just haven't got to it
yet but I'm not hearing anything from
you that's like government can come in
and set up a regime that's going to
do much for us is that your do you have
any hope in a sort of government
regulatory approach oh yeah I do I got
the test uh this also like reminds me
that like Google uh in the in the form
of uh Sundar pichai uh did uh react to
the letter uh like there was a podcast
uh hard Fork New York Times podcast
where he said that uh that like the
discussion started by the letter is
great uh but he thought that like
government intervention is necessary
here that is not enough uh to rely on on
the labs kind of self-regulating
uh so like
I think like one silver lining that I
already mentioned is that like this
pre-training is is super
expensive and super visible and
therefore like uh like it take to count
the metaphor that I that I've been using
is like the nuclear control uh that the
nuclear
nuclear arms uh you also have like these
two phases one is like the hard step of
enriching uranium which is like super
energy energy intensive as well as uh
like much more visible than the Second
Step which is harder to control which is
the proliferation of nuclear grade
material so like here we have the
similar situation where the pre-training
is actually happens
just in a few places and this is visible
to governments
whereas like the proliferation is
already much harder to control so so
yeah my model is that
and also like it as I know it it kind of
resonates with uh with uh
thinking uh in the labs themselves that
if you want to kind of have some
constraints
on the trajectory then I can hit a
winning uh in this compute
uh having some kind of compute
governance uh is is probably great thing
to start from and in fact like this
chips act and like the export controls
to China are already things that are
happening uh and uh in some ways make
the problem much much more easier uh
although it doesn't it's far from
solving it I think that makes sense I
mean
certainly at the moment the compute
requirements are are high I do wonder
what do you make of things like
the
diffusion of just language model
know-how proliferation
we I think we might have a guest coming
up on the podcast that is building a
decentralized GPU cluster potentially
with some sort of blockchain governance
where you know my M1 or M2 MacBook Air
can like contribute to a cluster
um do you think like how long do you
think we have before
that barrier of just like Mega compute
resources goes away possibly because of
these like virtual clusters or possibly
because of like further algorithmic
breakthroughs or just model leaks could
be another thing how long do you think
that holds
I mean I gotta refer back to this like
lasers more slow math science but yep
like with every every year or a couple
of years uh the destroying the world
becomes easier uh so uh there's that but
uh also like
if you do not get a pause like uh do you
think that the world will be destroyed
by one of the big Labs uh so it's just
because yeah the front-end models happen
it's much easier to train Frontier
models in a big
data center done in a distributed manner
that said if the post does happen then
yes we have to worry about things like
proliferation uh things like hackers uh
taking the hackers stealing that
stealing the weights and then kind of
doing the experiments uh like
chaos GPT but on uh with a combatant AI
stuff like that I think one of the maybe
most kind of
I don't know if it's an argument or
whatever but maybe one of the things
that's kind of hardest to
argue with in my experience with for
those that are kind of objecting to the
letter
or the to the concept of a pause is the
is the sense that like
someone might say you have no you're not
giving me anything to Hope on here
really right you're just telling me like
every every generation it gets easier
for the world to get destroyed like
we've talked about buying ourselves some
time here and there
um but we have we haven't really heard
much of a sort of here is the path we
can take to safety
um and so like why bother pausing if we
don't even have a sense of where we're
going
do you have any the hopes for concrete
paths to safety that you would try to
inspire that kind of person with yeah I
mean sort of humanity you have cancer
so it's like you might be cured of it
but current it doesn't look good so it's
like I'm not gonna lie it the prognosis
is bad
but like it's not hopeless I'd also like
to kind of like silver massive Silver
Lining is that if we do manage
to survive the cancer the future is
going to be amazing
so like in some ways uh kind of the
expected value of the future
is not bad it's just like the odds of
survival are bad but if you survive uh
that the light the life of the world the
universe could be potentially like
like unfortunately unfathomably better
than it did it is now so we in in sense
we are living living a lottery ticket uh
and it is in some way in our control to
improved odds and so that's what I'm
doing well that's probably about as good
of a bottom line as we could hope for
for this conversation so
uh I want to thank you for spending the
time with us I do have a couple real
quick hitter just fun questions that I
usually end on if you have an extra
second for those
we touched on this earlier
any applications aside from like the
obvious you know kind of usage of the
core language models that you are
personally just finding delightful or
useful that you would recommend that
people check out uh no I'm just like way
gonna bandwidth uh limited to to Tinker
uh with the language models I mean I
I've done a little bit uh but then I
I'm trying to find coders at this point
uh to like delegate points on my
projects some of them including
some of them might involve language
models
fair enough you're in the majority on
that answer most people are just using a
few things
and then second
um let's imagine a world where we're
here in a couple years and
neuralink has been deployed to one
million people
in this scenario you are well
um so you don't you don't need it for
restoring any functionality but if you
were to get a neuralink implant in your
head it would give you the ability to
essentially transmit your thoughts to
devices so you would have effectively
thought to text or thought to UI control
would that be enough for you to be
interested in getting a neural ink
implant depends so much on details like
how reversible is the procedure what are
the risks and what is they're going to
demonstrated upside like will I become a
better dancer as a result
we'll have to yeah that when I they did
show uh in their in their Show and Tell
they did show an animal where they were
creating motor control uh through the
neuralink but
yeah I think it was a long way from
improving on Your Dancing skills so I
hope you are dancing for many years to
come yantolin thank you so much for
spending this time with us we appreciate
you being part of the cognitive
Revolution
thank you very much